is it your view that ish about 80 of
women are childless due to life
circumstances
that's exactly what my point in it there
was a study done by Professor rinska
Kaiser which was a meta study and that's
the exact number he came up with
um and this kind of supported by other
evidence out there so uh Professor
Kaiser identified 10 of women who
medically could never have had children
there was something fundamentally sadly
that meant that they couldn't another 10
percent uh were women who had chosen not
their children and as Judy day says
there's a whopping 80 percent like her
who always plant her children and
through pure circumstances
the biggest circumstance being not
having the right partner at the right
time
in the right time meaning when you're
you know in your fertility window
so uh yes 80 just to drill that home
eighty percent of women and this is meta
studies replicated pretty robust as far
as it goes
yes uh childless due to life
circumstances and the most common life
circumstance is that they didn't have
the right partner what about having the
right partner and uh wait it's a one one
side of this would be single tennis I
suppose would be contributed to by being
single
another element would be having a
partner and then deciding to wait did
you look at how that gets split up
within that 80 percent
um well for sure I mean I I
I there's a quote in my mind that might
be from Julie day again that there's
like 50 different ways to be childless
there's so many possibilities of what
can happen in the circumstances of life
um but what I my interpretation of it is
this today uh you may know that the
majority of college students in the US
and actually most other countries are
women so today undergraduate students in
the US there's nine and a half million
female women and 6.5 million men
and it's 30 less
and there was a study done on on Tinder
uh by uh again I think it was a Dutch
University against University I believe
that showed that women on Tinder uh
effectively swipe right 91 more of the
time if someone has a master's degree as
a Man compared to you know yeah
bachelor's degree so women want to match
with someone at least as educated as
they are but yet the number of men
through the education system so this is
one of the challenges women are looking
competing with each other for a pool of
men that aren't really there anymore but
as well as that I think as a woman and
I'm conscious that I I you know I'm a
man and you know I have a daughter a
mother sisters uncle's aunts but I'm
still this is my perspective of what I'm
looking at from a man so apologies if
that offends anybody but
my belief is that women going through
education you studied year 22 23 uh you
might have some college debt you want to
get started on the career path you want
to work for three four five years to get
established because you know when you
have your first child things are going
to change and you've just studied for
four years at college and you've got
college debt so why are you even going
to think about having a child or even
being in a relationship necessarily that
would be with the right partner to be a
father of a child until you're getting
close to around 30 when things change
seem to change
and you know one of the facts that that
came up across every country we looked
at was that women turning 30 without a
child if you're childless at 30 the at
most you've got a 50 chance of ever
becoming a mother and that's maximum
it's actually lower than that in most
countries I could not find anywhere any
example so it's a toss of a coin turning
30 without it without it without a child
now now we're in this situation maybe
where you're into your early 30s and
you're hearing about egg freezing you're
hearing about
technologies that might make you think
it's okay to delay things well I I
interviewed five fertility doctors
including Kim Kardashian's uh fertility
doctor in La uh fertility doctor in
Tokyo
um and they're all saying the same thing
that we overestimate these Technologies
we not only overestimate the chance egg
freezing and IVF will work we don't take
into account that as women's bodies get
older the chance of not going full term
gets higher and higher
so
we get to the point I think early 30s as
a woman we're now thinking well I should
look for the right partner
but you might not meet that right person
it might take two years three years to
meet that right person now you're 35.
and you know what you might find age 35
he wasn't the person for you and now
you're 38.
and this is a life story of so many
people I met so many women in their 30s
it's like where did life go I had to
kind of follow this path I had to pursue
my dream my education my career and I'm
not one to for a second say that's wrong
but I think we have to make people aware
of the younger age that the challenges
are probably going to be greater to
maintain fertility to a point in the
moment where you kind of are ready and
at the same time to have a partner it's
it's it's it's much more difficult than
I think people estimate what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
face
[Music]